we just heard there from the government
saying that the chancellor and the new
prime minister are at one with their
vision for the country do you agree
no I don't and I think the last three
weeks have been quite frankly a disgrace
and an embarrassment to anyone who cares
about this country and the people who
live here I mean look the damage has
been done already you know whatever
moves we see from the conservative party
whoever gets a chance of being
Chancellor this month or whoever frankly
is prime minister by next week people's
mortgages are higher than they needed to
be business investment will be lower
than it otherwise would have been and
government expenditure and the pressures
on that will be worse because of
decisions that were made and I think
every time conservative ministers come
on and pretend that somehow this isn't
their responsibility confidence only
diminishes in them still further and
there are real world consequences to
that
I just want to talk to you about the
interview that we did at the beginning
of the program with Rob Halford and the
chair of the education select committee
he accused the government of blowing up
the party and the country and said that
Liz truss's government was treating the
country's laboratory mice to carry out
Ultra free market experiments
Labor's position on the number of
conservative MPS who are clearly
concerned about the direction of the
government and are you having
conversations with them
look we're always open for conversations
but quite frankly what this country
needs is is not conversations in
Westminster it needs a general election
where the public will get there say on
the future of government policy rather
than being decided anywhere else I mean
let's just look at you know who is in
charge of this government what are this
government's policies what which bits of
the budget still apply I genuinely don't
know the answers to those questions and
frankly what is required is fresh ideas
I think that requires a labor government
and I don't see how the conservative
party keeps believing it can change
Chancellor or even leader without the
public having their say
um I just want to talk about reports in
the paper that delaying that the
government's now considering delaying
the Wimpy cutter in income tax now that
would of course mean that in some ways
labor further to the right than the
conservatives on tax because you said
that you'd back the 1p cut to income tax
in April next year is that still your
position or are you changing with the
government
well our position has always been that
personal taxes in the UK are high
because growth has been so low so dismal
for the last 12 years so we've been
completely consistent in endorsing that
change now clearly what I need to know
what we all need to know is what the
state of the national finances really
are after this incredible damage that
the conservative party has done to them
so I need the obr forecast in order to
make any kind of assessment around that
I think that's the only reasonable
position to take but we are confident
that we could have a higher level of
economic growth than the conservative
body because our policies are not based
on you know this misplaced sense of
trickle down by cutting taxes for people
at the top hours are based on long-term
business investment and long-term
industrial strategy but clearly so if I
need to know what the real picture is we
all need that before we can make any
further decisions and to be frank we
don't know which bits of the budget
still apply or not this morning
do you think that some people are
listening to you might be a little bit
concerned though you know you're saying
they're about look don't worry uh our
growth will be higher than the
conservatives growth after what's
happened over the last month with you
know the argument that look you perhaps
don't need the same fiscal constraints
because growth will be high don't you
think people will think oh yeah I've
heard this one before higher growth that
means we don't have to be as responsible
with the finances and just won't buy it
it's not about being irresponsible with
the finances I mean first of all I would
say look the key problem in the British
economy is that business investment is
the lowest in the G7 and because of what
the conservative party has done might
even be near the bottom of the G20 so
long-term industrial strategy is a real
way to drive that up reforming business
rates improving our trading relationship
with the European Union improving skills
these are all real things but we've also
been absolutely clear that what
dominates for us what the overriding
rule is as Rachel Reeves has set out is
fiscal responsibility and that means we
will not borrow for day-to-day spending
we don't believe as a conservatives do
you can borrow money to pay for tax cuts
for the well-off and somehow that will
make everything better we're absolutely
clear on that and that will always apply
and will make decisions once we have
seen the obr forecasts but there is no
doubt for us fiscal responsibility rules
and I think that's been endorsed
entirely frankly with what we've seen in
the last three weeks
let's talk about fiscal responsibility
shall we because what I was very
interested to hear from Andrew Griffith
was that we've previously been told that
this government is going to be sticking
to the current spending envelopes that
is now not necessarily uh true he says
all things are on the table so that does
potentially mean uh spending not Rising
as fast as we were expecting would a
labor government spend more than the
conservatives on public services
but we would only spend more on
day-to-day Public Services where we can
identify additional Revenue that would
pay for that so for instance abolishing
the non-dumbreal brings in over 3
billion pounds we would tax private
Equity income differently to how the
conservatives do it so we're absolutely
clear on that I do want to say however
any spending cuts the conservative party
brings forward are entirely of its own
making I mean listro did give a
commitment in prime minister's questions
on Wednesday which said absolutely there
would be no spending costs but anything
they bring forward will be solely on
them and their incompetence and quite
frankly looking at the state of the NHS
the criminal justice system Law and
Order in this country I don't see where
they're going to get a lot of this money
that they're hinting at so look our
spending envelope would be different
because we can identify additional
Revenue that we would bring in and
frankly we'd borrow less money because
our windfall tax would be more extensive
than the conservative one so we're clear
on on that bid but if the conservatives
think they can do austerity again the
state they've left the country in after
12 years I think they really need to
think quite seriously about where
they'll get that money from
does that mean that tax rate tax will go
up under labor
no it doesn't mean the tax will go up it
means additional sources of of Revenue
as I say like abolishing the non-dom
rule or the charitable status of private
schools being reviewed or other changes
to how private Equity is taxed we will
always identify where Revenue will come
from where we will increase day-to-day
spending but look anyone who doubts that
approach look at what happens when you
have a government that isn't committed
to that kind of fiscal responsibility it
means you're paying more on your
mortgage it means your workplace your
employer your business can't invest as
it wants to do it means the government
is paying more in the debt interest or
on the national debt so that there are
real world consequences to the kind of
irresponsibility we've seen from the
conservative party I just want to I just
want to come in labor party is committed
to that I just want to come in because
you know I'm no Economist but for me
these numbers are just nowhere near
adding up so you know we spoke to
Charlie Bean at the former official from
the bank of England he said there's a 40
billion pound black hole that needs to
be plugged in the things that you're
talking about you know private schools
can't be Charities 1.7 billion pounds I
mean that's not going to touch the sides
does it
well look I I can only make those
decisions based on real information from
the obr I know the forecasts I can't do
it off of newspaper speculation I mean
there are there are stories that have
been placed overnight by the government
or people leaking from it about
potentially very large sums of money but
that is the consequence of incompetence
so I need I need that information before
we can make further decisions about that
but being no doubt that for us our
fiscal rules and fiscal responsibility
will always govern any of the decisions
that we make